[Music]
today's question comes from katie in
michigan she says i'm engaged and my
fiancee currently has fifteen thousand
dollars in debt that he's paying off i
am debt free and currently have 18 000
in savings once we're married later this
year i would like to pay his remaining
debt but i would like for us to still
live below our means until we pay back
my savings he doesn't agree with this
plan help oh boy george exclamatory help
at the end there yeah for sure well
ken i i'm inclined to agree with katie
that it's important we refill this
emergency fund but i don't think he sees
it as that no and the problem is is uh
they're engaged and they are in the
final countdown right oh boy you you
don't want to
kick the can down the road and deal with
this after marriage
we got to find out where i feel like
this is how it's going okay time out
this is a emergency press conference
right yes we got to sit down and hash
through this
so here's what i'm thinking right now he
sees it as her plan
and his plan i think we need to get on
our plan
and that means he needs to understand
where she's coming from i don't know
that she's explained hey this money is
my emergency fund of three to six months
and if something were to happen i want
us to be protected from whatever happens
in the economy a job loss uh hvac needs
to be replaced whatever it is we need to
have the money in savings so that we
don't go into debt yeah and so i think
we need to have a mindset shift and
that's one of the beautiful things about
financial peace university when you go
through it as a couple you now have a
shared language that you can use to
communicate you understand where each
person is coming from and so i think
that would be a great next step for them
because currently they're on different
wavelengths when it comes to money and i
feel like i'd like to have a one-on-one
with this young man
he's yet to discover the universal truth
happy wife happy life
and uh you know he needs to figure this
out you know
not only because of that but because it
actually is the right decision but you
know come on man
figure this out this you got a you got a
really level-headed fiancee who's yeah
she's getting in the bank no debt she's
clearly doing something well she's
paying off this knucklehead's debt which
i appreciate when they get married i
appreciate that it becomes our money and
our financial mistakes yeah this katie i
got to tell you this is a full stop
we have got to dig into this you need to
know my heart on this
why i believe this
why i want you to do this
how it's important to the to the vision
that i have for our marriage that's the
key word
what is the vision for our family when
it comes to money
and i think once they nail that down
everything's going to be great but right
now this feels like a solvable problem
yeah oh it absolutely is but it is a red
flag